[Musique]
toy story de olé diego de khanishin
maurice n'est pas stoppée parce que
partisane
[Musique]
sur le carreau fna bon je veux amener
tous les quatre dernières najib au
moulin fut le préfet
il est brillant et à fond
[Musique]
en 40 ans 39
j'avais longues 7 ans à paris 15e
à côté de l'opéra côté 2 du métro gérard
et plaisance je voyais jouer les soldes
alors fallait que je devienne un jour
soldats dans ma taille
quelle occupation et moi j'étais dans la
rue j'en avais pas je vais pas réfléchir
sur les fleurs l'occupation je vais
réfléchir sur la résistance
c'est ça qui est important cash et des
prisonniers soviétiques évadés ont les
cachets des fois on avait deux trois à
la maison nous on avait à paris un
appartement 2 pièces une cuisine et y
avait pas de toilettes il fallait sortir
dans le couloir ferme la motte il de
couloir pour aller faire pipi et par on
cache une haut nil dans ce coin
[Musique]
il y avait des résidents des lieux
enfin début qu'avec 30 ans 40 ans est
souvent une demande du petit chose
ballon au début me disait etien va
porter ses plaies être là et là je suis
parti tout seul dans à faire tout ce que
je voulais mon frère avait sept ans de
plus que moi donc il avait 16 ans ils
s'étendent et il était lui dans la vraie
résistance et pas comme moi et lui il se
baladait avec un fusil et il tirait il
faisait la guerre
[Musique]
on avait des voix 2 3 sur l'isi qui m'a
dit qu'ils étaient chez nous de trois
jours il fallait que je m'emmêle un ou
deux ou trois dans un endroit il y avait
un autre mais à monsieur plus âgés que
moi qui les accueillait on était dans le
xvème à retenir et à côté de du métro
plaisance et je les emmenais à un pied
il a alors je partais à pied et eux me
suivait mais à 100 m alors moi mon seul
roule ses devoirs en gardant en passant
devant les magasins
regardez s'il s'est toujours derrière
moi et je les emmenais à travers paris
jusqu'à mon mari est en passant il y
avait une petite rue à droite je passais
devant il y avait un mur vin vieux 40
ans 50 ans un monsieur
on a fait un qui mâche continuer et eux
quand ils passaient ils homme disait pas
visible et il est emmené là c'était la
cachette
je ne savais pas où il en est
je n'avais pas le savoir par tous
simplement parce que s'il faisait
attraper un jour par les allemands
c'était là les habitants il rigolait pas
c'était le mur
[Musique]
et re luc non je faisais mon boulot
bêtement bon boulot
[Musique]
il y avait beaucoup de ruches émigrer
mais malheureusement beaucoup de russes
émigrés 138 du côté allemand dans ce
qu'il disait on va en l'air
staline l'armée rouge jaune à l'armé
blanche
ça s'est coupé en deux il voulait y
avait ceux qui étaient pour hitler ce
qui était pour staline mais la plupart
étaient quand même pour la russie
bouderont pas valide
[Musique]
c'était extraordinaire parce que nous
avions gagné
et comme j'ai connu le plus patient
allemande a pas en france
c'était j'étais vraiment quelque chose
de 2go grands
[Musique]
à bord c'est éviter la guerre faut
toujours éviter la guerre
avec la russie s'était beaucoup plus
sympa avec l'union soviétique quand vous
allez là bas j'avais eu loris petite
copine
[Musique]